- I feel like the name,
vada pav, is exactly
how feel when I take a bite.
- It's like vada pav!
(lively Indian music)
I've had Indian food before,
but never street food.
- I don't really know what
to expect with street foods.
'Cause when I go to a restaurant
there are a lot of sauces.
- Maybe it'll be something
that you can hold,
and walk with easier than a curry.
- There's probably gonna be spice in it.
I'm expecting that.
- Street food is usually
fast, casual, spicy.
- Yeah, I'm not sure what to expect.
And I think that's part of the
curiosity of it all, is that
what would be the difference?
- Ah yeah.
- Oh, yes.
- This looks so good.
- Fried, already great.
(moans)
- Oh my god.
- There's some red spice, creamy potatoes
on the inside, a nice hard,
crispy fry on the outside.
- The sauce is kind of sweet,
which makes it really nice.
- It's like an upgraded hashbrown.
- This is so good.
(laughs)
- Wow, it's a big Mac.
- It is so good.
- Oh my God.
- I think this is one of the best things
I've ever put in my mouth.
I'm not shitting you.
This is...
(bleep)
Beautiful.
- There's a spice, but a sweetness,
and then a kick from the onion, like...
This was very well
thought out, flavor wise.
- This is spicy for me.
My mouth is on fire right now.
But I wanna keep eating
it, because it's so good.
- You feel it there.
(hums)
- It's just such an insult, because it's
like for a McDonald's
burger to be two bucks,
and this is 60 cents
in India, like get out.
'Cause a McDonald's burger doesn't
even have half the flavor.
- You know what, they should have this
for sale outside every bar, in LA.
- In the world.
- This already looks like something a
health food store could sell for $15.
- There's a lot going on in here.
- Yeah, it's like puff rice, yeah.
- Chickpeas.
- [Man] Chickpeas, onions.
- Some kind of cracker.
- Oh, it's cold.
I don't know why I expect it to be hot.
- It's very sweet.
- But it's like sweet, but
refreshing at the same time.
- Each bite is just a
kaleidoscope of flavors.
- It's like a fried rice potato salad.
- It does remind me of
a fancy salad, right?
- Yeah.
- But then it's got this
sweet tamarind flavor
that I'm not expecting.
- It was...
I mean, it was great, because it was...
They were all things
I'd never tried before.
- And they gave me a newfound
respect for vegetarian food.
I mean, this was all...
These all didn't have meat in it.
And, they were delicious.
- I don't know why I was
expecting cone stuff.
Doesn't make any sense.
I was expecting curry in a cone.
I don't know.
- I feel like I'm just wrapped up in
a bunch of blankets, and there's puppies
giving me kisses.
- Ah.
- Great drunk food.
- I am so happy.
Best taste test ever.
- Yeah.
- So delicious.
- I'd really wanna try
Indian street desserts.
- Comment below if you'd
like to see us try.
(lively Indian music)